That's why I'm studying well. Well
, I've become able to read this kind of road. It was
fun to enjoy the subtle differences in common sense. It's
just like having a cross-cultural exchange.
The red demon and the crying red demon
Let's hear the fish roho. Let's listen
to the sound.
I was friends I wanted to make friends with the people of the village,
but people were scared and wouldn't approach me I couldn't
see I came up with a plan for the red demon
Then the villagers will surely stain you,
and the red demon became friends with the humans
, but as the days went by, I became worried.
It was a blue demon that hadn't visited since that day.
One day, I visited the blue demon's house on my face, and the
soil was tight and there was a sticker left behind.
It was written there:
Akaoni-kun, make friends with humans and live happily.
If I keep dating you, you might think that you are a bad demon.
I decided to go out,
but I'll never forget you Goodbye, please take good
care of your body,
forever, your friend
Oh
, I read it silently and many times.